okay the door closes and that's our cue
I think to start the presentation thank
you all for coming
the title of this talk is from circuit
board design to finished product the
hobbyist guide to hardware manufacturing
so what we'll learn today is basically
how to make cool stuff that you made by
yourself my name is sebastian roll i'm
educated as a chemical engineer from
trondheim started out in the oil and gas
industry pivoted to software worked as a
consultant a couple of years and now I'm
back in the oil and gas industry as a
software engineer so funny how that goes
I'm also co-founder of a small company
called byte barista where we do
workshops we do hardware design product
development and consulting as well so
the agenda for today looks like this
we're going to go through the steps of
making hardware through the PCB route
which involves component sourcing
finding components designing the PCB
assembly some experiences that we had as
well as hopefully some good demos we
have a lot of slides to go through today
so I'm gonna try to make it quick this
is us we are just three friends we all
have our day jobs but in the evening we
have a lot of time on our hands and we
spend some time in our makerspace hack
I'm Antoine I'm it's me Sebastian and
it's hans elias Josephson and martin
unison della and dog he's the brain of
the organization
this summer we attended Euro Python
which is the biggest Python conference
in in Europe in Switzerland it was and
we held a workshop for some 30 attendees
where we used this thing that we made
and the idea was that we wanted to have
a workshop where people can learn about
IOT concepts in a most an accessible way
as possible so that involves not
connecting things together you just get
a device you use your micro Python which
is an embedded language for embedded
programming and you get started so this
turned into not only a workshop but we
also had a poster session where we
described the process of how we designed
and produced this and we had a full day
sprint at the end where people would
come and contribute to the source code
that we have in our github repository so
how is our what did our process our
adventure looked like usually it goes
like this you start out with a
breadboard maybe you go onwards to a
proto board in the middle or a strip
board that's a little bit different
straight board you have rows or columns
are connected and then if you get all
the way through and you still have some
motivation you design your own printed
circuit board yeah you've probably seen
this before maybe you've done it before
it's great to see how one component
works it can get a little bit messy if
you have multiple components and it's
also a little bit of a hassle if you
leave your project some light wires
might come loose it's not easy to do our
control
we had a presentation where we wanted to
discuss micro Python as a language and
we wanted to demo it and just to show
how easy it is to get stuff done with a
high-level language so we made this is a
box that's a laser-cut and you have a
display in the middle a joystick on the
left a microphone and at the bottom
there to push buttons and a rotary
encoder and at the very top you can
maybe see a micro SD card so it had a
micro SD card slot as well and we
presented a tin NDC Ostrow 2018 and also
tong M Developer Conference but if you
look inside the demo gods I think I
spent all my goodwill with the demo gods
because this thing actually worked
during the conference but up until the
presentation it was really a hassle to
get this thing to work because all of a
sudden one lot a wire comes loose when
you lift it up and then you have 30
minutes of just trying to figure out
where should it go how do I use supply
like a little tiny plier to connect it
again
you see the breadboard there on the left
left hand side with a microcontroller
attached so this was not a good
long-term solution but we tried I was a
little bit naive at the start we were
scheduled for a two day workshop and I
laser-cut boxes and bought a lot of
components and got ready for the equi
new developer conference now the people
there are very good programmers but if
you ask them to learn a new language
micro Python you ask them to learn how
to connect this stuff together to learn
all the new components how do we work
find drivers it's an impossible task
even for two days it's very difficult so
what we ended up with was something more
like this akin to this you have a
microcontroller in the middle you have a
temperature sensor and then you display
the values temperature and humidity on a
display and you can see already there
how many wires are
crossing and if you find a problem here
it's very hard to debug is it a
connection issue did I get the right
driver on my laptop firmware is very
difficult so we were scheduled for
another workshop and a presentation at
Google dev fest in Trondheim so we
decided to take it one step further
let's make a proto board the second the
next step and it looks a little bit
better we're using sensor modules here
so you just connect it directly the
proto board you can see the differences
that use solder the connections between
the components beforehand so it doesn't
disassemble as easily however it took us
one to two hours to solder in one of
these proto boards so it was a grueling
weekend we managed to produce seven of
these and on we go to the workshop we
had a presentation the workshop is
actually it goes much more fluently now
because now people have a device in
their hands and it's already connected
you start thinking about the software
about the concepts Hardware concepts and
people are able to produce things much
quicker so in this image to the right we
have this controller box which is
controlling this remote toy car over
Wi-Fi using MQTT and it has a microphone
on there and a LED display and a little
buzzer so people were able to to control
it using the box which was a lot of fun
ok here comes the big test we are
accepted for NDC Oslo for a 2-day
workshop and also for a presentation but
we figure this is this is very difficult
to do a repeatable thing making box
after box after box if there's so much
manual labor so let's design our own PCB
so moving away from the story a little
bit let's talk about what a printed
circuit board is it's a substrate in the
middle of a non conductive material
it's give structural strength and then
you have one or more copper layers and
then on top of the copper layers you
have something called a solder mask
which is the thin lacquer like material
made out of polymer and that is to
conduct to insulate on the copper except
where you want exposed copper and then
on top you have a silkscreen where you
can put text so that's kind of printing
on top of the PCB you design the printed
circuit board using a dedicated software
which we'll get into some of them are
very expensive some of them are free and
it's produced an multi-step process
the last description I saw had 18
separate steps so we're not going to go
into that either why would you want to
design a PCB the PCB holds your
components together it connects them
together and you don't have to manually
make the connections you do it in the
software and then it's printed you it
allows for you to have multiple layers
so you can take one one track from one
component to another and then go to the
other side of the PCB and and then back
up again if you want it allows for
smaller components very small components
and it reduces the human error concept
because you have less human interaction
with it and it's a pricing lee low cost
you can order five PCBs for $2 now with
free shipping from China okay so making
a PCB device let's split into four steps
you first want to find which component
you want to use what is the
functionality I want then you want to
figure out how this component works make
sure that you know how to have it behave
and the intended way and then you design
the PCB at the end you order the PCB the
components and assemble it together so
first finding the components you have so
many components different types of
sensors input devices microcontrollers
it's very hard it's impossible to keep
track
here is a list of some of the more
reputable brands some are more obscure
brands but you want to use a distributor
in order to buy these things so the
distributor you go there to their
website you search for microphone you
get hundreds of hits and then you figure
out what type of microphone do I want
and then from there you can buy from
many different manufacturers from our
experienced digi-key and Mouser was a
little bit too expensive for our
hobbyist goals arrow is a giant company
but they have decided to target the
hobby market so they offer free shipping
now for one component you can buy and
they offer free shipping which is very
nice and they have good competitive
prices LCSC is a Chinese company and
they have in on this list the cheapest
components that we found we used arrow
and LCSC in our adventure there's also
something called aggregators so if you
decide I want this microphone I have a
model number for it you can go to octo
part or find chips-- and search for that
model number and you will get all the
distributors that sell it and you can
choose the one with the cheapest price
if you want okay and then there is ollie
Express eBay I don't have to explain I
don't think what that is they have very
very low prices free shipping from China
I've used it constantly my girlfriend is
not happy with the packages come at the
worst it's multiple packages per day but
it goes in yeah in waves
you also have Alibaba Group which is
kind of like Aliexpress when you want to
buy 50 or 10,000 of that same thing and
what what the thing here is about is
that you are you search through
Aliexpress or Alibaba and then you are
put into touch with distributor with the
sales so that would be a smaller company
perhaps and then you might negotiate a
price with this company so it's a little
bit different you might get
you might risk getting lower quality or
defect items worst case some of them
don't ship with anti-static bags so the
the previous slides has that more
covered but I have to say we've also
used Alibaba and all the Express and
been very happy with them
this is the BBM II 280 it's produced by
Bosch and it's an environment sensor so
it sounds as temperature humidity and
pressure a small note about finding this
component in the right place the price
range that we found for this component
went from $2 to 30 to 35 dollars so
that's a 15 fold difference in price but
you have this you decide you want this
you want to use it on the top left here
you have the sensor itself so what you
do is you look for you try to find the
datasheet for this sensor the BMI BMI
280 and in the datasheet you will
normally find what's called a typical
application circuit or a connection
diagram and this will help you to know
how to introduce it into your design
into your PCB design and what you see on
the right here is someone has already
designed what is that typical connection
diagram and maybe a little bit different
and they offer it as sensor module that
you can connect directly to the
microcontroller so that's what that
looks like the PCB a small word on
communication protocols I don't know how
familiar you are with these spi and icrc
are very popular standards I can just
say briefly that many sensors use one of
these two and it's not actually that
hard to learn how to use them many times
drivers for the components already exist
so then it becomes trivial how to use
the sensor that you buy
okay then we know what components we
want we want to design the PCB I checked
the price for one of the leading
commercial PCB design tools or sweets
that the corporate domain uses the
bigger companies and that start the
starter price was over $7,000 a year so
that doesn't suit our tastes as well
being hobbyists so I'm gonna briefly
mention three free software that you can
use there's been a proliferation of this
the last maybe five to ten years which
is excellent for us hobbyists one is
Fritzing I haven't used this myself but
it's open source and free is a desktop
application it has these nice pictures
as you can see other components which is
helpful if you're not super familiar
about what the names of these components
are the types they also have a nice
breadboard prototyping design which is
nice if you want to kind of save your
prototype design instead of taking a
picture and then you have something
called EC EDA which is also free they
have an online version and a desktop
version one cool feature with this
program is that when you design when you
have your circuit diagram made and you
have your schematic and then you decide
which type of specific components you
want to use you the program will check
availability for those components in LS
LCSC the Chinese distributor and you it
will automatically create the bill of
materials for you so then when you're
done you can just instead of clicking
save you can click order and then you
get all the things that you need to make
it and you can also it also includes jlc
PCB which is PCB manufacture then on to
the program that we've used this is
called Chi CAD and it's GPL licensed it
has a huge community it's quite advanced
so since it has a huge community it has
tons of designs already
available for you so you can just add
the BME to a tee temperature sensor it's
your diagram and you're good to go it
also has a push and shove router which
means in the layout when you draw the
the connections how the physical
connections coordinate gonna be it will
push out existing connections if there's
not enough room so you don't have to
redraw all the connections you made
already which is a nice feature so how
does the workflow look like you start by
drawing the schematic then you assign
component footprints
next you draw the layout you order the
PCB and the components you build it and
then you test it and then it didn't work
of course so you go but and iterate
again you have to expect at least a
couple of one or a couple iterations so
the first part of drawing a schematic
this is what that looks like it's a
circuit diagram with it's like a
symbolic representation of your circuits
so they will have standardized symbols
it will not be a realistic 2-dimensional
layout of how the PCB will be but since
there's a schematic it's the best way to
actually understand the circuit that's
where you want to go if you want to
learn about how it works then from the
schematic you want to assign footprints
for each component that you have
introduced so a footprint would be how
the component would fit onto the PCB so
for a resistor for example they have
tons of different dimensions tons of
different physical designs
so the footprint would specify that
physical design there are so many
available you probably won't have to
draw your own footprint but if you have
to do that it's actually quite simple to
learn next
you have schematic footprints now you're
ready to make the actual physical layout
so that means you import whatever your
schematic and footprints and you get all
the components clustered in the middle
and then you have to place all the
components where you want them to be on
your on your PCB
and you also draw all the connections
between them here you have an example of
a schematic to the left and a layout to
the right and the schematic the yellow
thing in a schematic corresponds to the
uppermost thing you can see on the
layout and then you can see some white
lines there and the white lines are
indications of what you need to connect
with tracks so it will help you you
don't have to memorize how it was
supposed to be connected and lastly some
tools including Chi CAD has a 3d viewer
it's good to see how your product will
look in the end maybe your 3d designing
and in case a case for it
then it's useful to know plus it just
looks really cool so it's a good
motivation you should always check the
3d viewer if you want to go for one more
hour so we've done the we're finished
with the design now it's time to order
an assemble you have many many types of
PCB manufacturers I list three of them
because they are the ones I've been told
about the most dirty PCBs they are dirt
cheap they're good for projects if you
can if you can allow or accept a higher
margin of error because they're not so
accurate but they're very cheap on the
right you have PCB way they have they
offer assembly in addition so that's
nice and in the middle you have jl pc
PCB which is the one we used we also are
sponsored by them we got some coupons
to help us out and yeah part of the demo
was supposed to be designing an actual
PCB from scratch and then ordering it
from jlc PCB just to show how that you
can actually do this in five or ten
minutes for a simple circuit but alas we
don't have time for that so we're going
to do something else
now on to assembling how do you assemble
this that you have you have hand
soldering which is very good for
prototyping simple circuits some
through-hole components means that you
push the component through the PCB and
then solder it on the other side it's
very good for troubleshooting if
something is not working you maybe take
off one components so it's always good
to have available but you don't want to
do the entire process using hand
soldering so I can quickly show you how
that looks like we're assembling the
buttons here and then hand soldering
them one by one okay when you order your
PCB you might want to at the same time
order a stencil and what that is it's a
plate with holes where the PCB wants to
have solar paste so you put the PCB
above below it and then you apply solder
paste a very very thin layer on top of
the stencil just one go and you have
solar paste exactly on the pads where
you're supposed to have it so that looks
like this there are small tiny silver
pellets on the top you can see it's been
bridged there's a bridge between it and
its heat treated and you have two ways
of actually heating up that I know you
have hot air gun and then you have this
reflow oven which is very nice you get a
uniform heat everything attaches
properly using an air hot air gun is
harder but it's doable we did both
lastly if you really want to go at it
you have a pick-and-place machine where
you don't have to manually place all the
components you just have a machine to do
it for you instead if you have a high
volume then it might be reasonable to do
it there's one at bit off the makerspace
in oslo they have one so you can use you
can have a higher density of components
but as far as I know you can all you
only use its tube connected surface
mounted components and it also takes a
time a little bit of time because you
have to create the program to put
together so this is what we came up with
we wanted to make something that was fun
that has a lot of components and I can
just quickly run through the physical
layout in the back we have an ESP 32
microcontroller which has this
particular has 8 megabytes of RAM 4
megabytes of Flash it's 320
I think megahertz dual dual core
processor so it's pretty powerful here
we have three-and-a-half millimeter
output you have some breakouts here and
here that you can solder if you want
looking at the front then you have some
input devices you have the direction pad
you have an analog version of the
direction pad you have four buttons here
and then this is a nice feature with the
ESP 32 you can connect directly to the
microcontroller one wire and you can
configure it to be a touch sensor so
that's a small little touch pad here you
have the BME 280 environment sensor this
is a 9 axis motion sensor it's called an
MP unit 9250 you have a GPIO extender
this is a micro SD card reader so this
would be SPI
these would be I square C you have here
a little preamp amplifier with a
microphone
MEMS microphone is called you have the
same circuit here with a speaker and an
amplifier you have four addressable RGB
LEDs and then you have the capacitive
touch display in the middle here which
is 240 by 320 nine 16-bit
let's have a look at the schematic this
is how the schematic looks looks like
let's change the color here is the
microcontroller and then you have many
different types of devices you can see
that they're not physically connected
and that's because if you use a label it
says here Joey Y and then you repeat
that label then that counts as a
connection Joey Y so this is the thumb
slide joystick so that's very nice so it
doesn't look like one connected thing
here we're swimming in at DME 280 and
here you can see it has two pins here
the clock pin connected to the
microcontroller and the data pin and the
rest is just a copy-paste from the
application circuit onto the layout that
looks like this what you see here is the
front and the back of the PCB at the
same time so the front would be the
brown wires there there the front and
the green is on the back and also
swimming in at the BM e 280 you should
have given it a little bit more space
for the for the text but it works here
is the 3d design for the first version
that we made and also the manufactured
PCB for the first and the second version
so we had to make three for a small demo
we'll try see
so the demos we're not going to write
any code we're just going to run a
couple of demos instead so I have to do
it kind of I have to mirror my brain in
order to get this to work so you go up
and down here for some choices the first
one is a Tetris clone called tetrax that
is this is all written from scratch in
in micro Python by a C++ programmer
Moulton is very affected then the next
one is a snake clone yeah that's how it
goes when you mirror the next one is a
weather report so here you have
temperature and humidity the bar to your
left would be the temperature so yeah it
updates I think every second
and you can go even further and of
course Moulton made also a 3d dungeon
game which I don't can you see it yeah
yes yes he's really good but he doesn't
like to share his code because he's not
a programmer he's actually a biotech guy
so he's not really he hasn't been doing
a lot of like collaboration so he has
weird variable names and stuff so it has
a little mini map at the bottom there
I'm not able to go oh ok here you can
walk around no ghosts there yet and two
more demos this is a little vertical
scroller platform thing this is to
demonstrate the hardware the display
driver has this scrolling hardware
scrolling functionality so you get a
very nice framerate and then lastly he
made this in May this yesterday in a few
hours just to give you an impression of
how this high-level language can can get
you productive so how are you using the
capacitive touch and you're adjusting
the brightness and the color and then
you can lock the LEDs I just locked two
of them and then you can change the ones
that are not locked so yeah that's a lot
of fun
that was the demo now how much thank you
how much did this cost four components
it would be around 50 US dollars I think
we could push this down to maybe 40 or
45 but then you have to add value-added
tax if you're shipping it to Norway
they're shipping itself some you usually
use DHL or UPS or something similar like
that that costs money and what they also
do is that they paid the value-added tax
on your behalf and then they add it to
the bill and of course there's an extra
fee for that which could range from
twenty to forty dollars for every
shipment we also went through a lot of
prototypes you had to make some
prototypes billed them you're not going
to be able to sell them obviously and
also we had quite a few manufacturer
errors we try to assemble it something
didn't work a short circuit something
like that
but we're selling them right now for 79
euros so if you have some someone at
home some teenager that wants to learn
how to code or it's fun for a grown-up I
can promise you that as well we're sold
out buy right now but we're producing
more okay so let's talk about how we
failed you have the design fails if you
see the micro SD card reader there's
something wrong there it's because in
the design we it's upside down so now
you're not able to to put in a micro SD
card or remove it if you already
assemble the 3d printed d-pad and then
for the thumb slide right below here's
the layout for the first version you
guys see I problem here yeah the what
happens here is that these circles are
through-hole circles so it's actually
cutting one of the tracks here
and that's one of the lessons if you see
it on top there's a small ladybug second
symbol that's a design rules check so if
you click that it would actually pop up
you have an error here so we learn how
to use that button after this this is
the push buttons in the middle the four
push buttons we wanted some sort of to
be able to use conductive rubber to push
down and it would short-circuit this
grid like this is a thing here if you
see the ground goes down to this part
should be the ground but then it also
connects here to the other side so it's
already 1 or 0 it's already connected in
the wrong way so for all of the version
to PCBs we had to manually cut this out
we had assembly fails to don't worry
this is molten we when we when you get
the components you usually get them in a
cut strip like a strip with without you
open up and we wanted all the resistor
values available and wanted in them in
the small boxes because when you
assemble it it's nice to be able to just
use pliers and put it instead of opening
up the strip so we spent the whole day
putting these into boxes and the next
day I managed to drop it in the floor
and what happens there of course all the
resistor values blend together and we
don't have Cinderella on our team so
that was a sad face some so luring
issues we used at the start a hot-air
gun which is great but it kind of
localizes the heat so the heat
dissipates very quickly if you put too
much solder paste on the stencil what
you're going to have is you're going to
bridge some other paths there so we had
a short circuit path spur bridge and
what you do then is that use flux and
then you you apply your solder tip
downwards and downwards along the pads
and eventually you will remove the
bridge
but since we have four layers the upper
copper layer is very fragile so if you
use too much force you're just going to
tear all the pads yeah we had the same
issue with the display as you can see it
was not easy at the start we were also
learning Hans is the only guy who
actually has some experience yeah so
with this issue especially with the NP
you 9250 happened a lot because it it's
much smaller than the other sensors so
here you have a graveyard of defect
devices yeah to make matters worse we
both got quite serious repetitive strain
injuries so I was out I had issues with
my elbows cubital tunnel syndrome I
still do and Hans had issues more like
carpal and muscle stuff he tried to make
a nice setup ergonomic setup but we were
struggling we were really struggling for
this workshop at NDC but we were so we
were so lucky that people in the very
last week people showed up everyday
people showed up to help us assembling
it testing it with the design they
helped us write the tutorials for the
workshop and at the end we had some
controllers ready ready to ship packed
it up and we had our workshop not as
many people as we were worried might
show up which is great but it I think
everyone had a great time we people get
so enthusiastic and immersed when they
have physical things they can interact
with with code and people were skipping
coffee breaks actually more than half of
the coffee breaks we were just sitting
in listening to some house music and
encoding the presentation we had to
cancel because our so much pain after
the workshop but that's this
presentation so I'm very happy to get
the chance to present here at Andy
SeaTac town
lastly we have some tips and tricks for
you let's just go through first the
component sourcing process use
aggregators like octo parts you get the
best price for the component that you
wanna use by at least two samples that's
important at least we bought the
displays from China it took a while to
get it and then the first thing we did
was to destroy the first sample by
plugging the microcontroller the wrong
way find proper documentation for your
components go through data sheets it's
readily available and check if there's
someone who already made a driver for
the component then it's very simple to
just start using it ensure availability
reliability if you find the component
make sure that they have enough that you
need and that they are reliable enough
that if you actually need to have a
workshop ready then make sure that
they're they're trustworthy that they
have they're reputable I would say and
lastly consider lead time so for the
displays when we were ready we tested
the samples yes we got it to work we
want now 100 displays okay that's going
to be four weeks lead time because they
have to produce them first
so that was a problem for us luckily
they had enough in stocks for the ones
that we made for the PCB design consider
using a dedicated ground and VCC layers
so for us that would mean we have four
copper layers
the top and the bottom is for signals
and then in the middle you have one cup
ground layer and one VCC layer that
makes it very simple if you have a
component you're supposed to connect to
ground here and here you just send it
straight to that layer then place
surface-mounted components on one of the
layers either top or the bottom because
you're going to place all these at once
and you're going to put it in the oven
and then you don't want to have to flip
it and do it again if you are unsure
where to connect your pin some of these
pin has something called an I Square C
address you should I pull this pin to
VCC or to some other pin you can just
make a track for both of them and
make like a zero ohm resister footprint
and then when you are ready to assemble
it you just put a serie on resistors on
one of them so you actually close the
circuit on one of them keep them on
other open add capacitors if it wasn't
for capacitors you could just take
copy-paste
all of the schematics from the data
sheets and it will work and with without
capacitors it might work but you want to
add capacitors there close to where the
components that drain some power to make
sure you don't get power spikes and
stuff like that perform electrical and
the science rules check that's the
little ladybug in the schematic and the
layout and also there's a Inkscape
plug-in called SVG to chenchen where you
can make your design in SVG and you can
import it as the PCB design file and you
can make some crazy designs
some examples are here assembly if
you're in doubt use flux flux help makes
your life easier it's that secret sauce
that you put to make sure that
everything solders nice and easy is also
easy to remove parts using flux if your
solder paste is dry which in our case it
was it messed up our MP use motion
sensor you can make some flux in there
that will help do not over apply solder
paste on the stencil you get too much
solder like more than you need use
proper tools use a proper soldering iron
that really helps along and then write
test firmware so that when you assemble
it you know I can test it check
immediately what works and what does not
work lastly when you're done with all
this you thought it was fun learning
experience but you don't want to have to
open up a web show up you don't have to
produce there's something there's some
serve service providers that offer you
everything you just give them the design
file they will manufacture the PCB for
you they will source the components for
you you just give them a bill of
materials they will find where to buy
them they will assemble them for you
they will keep it in stock for you they
will have a webshop so they handle sales
and they also handle distribution
usually from China so then it's a free
shipping as well
that would also get rid of the
value-added tax I think so it's a really
nice way we haven't done that yet but
we're considering it if we get a big
like order book and maker perhaps is one
of the companies that I heard about so
that was the end of the presentation I
hope you learned something we definitely
learned a lot along the way mistakes are
okay to do you can expect it but you're
not going to probably find yourself in a
deadlock where you can never get past it
it is actually absolutely doable and
when you have us this device in your
hand it feels great thank you very much
[Applause]